bachelor finale was last night here's
the high point we just made a big circle
it's a trash fire that it is grass fire
the show boiled down to a vacuous CAD
proposing to a woman after he'd
previously proposed to then dumped and
humiliated on live television
a different gal and yes I said gal
sounds good
I've made some bad decisions but the
best decision was running back to you
Vernon maybe that's a mistake the second
woman accepted the proposal from this
snore of a boar because you know love
conquers all especially when a producer
demands it now that other dumped woman
confronted the jerk about his deceitful
character and he apologized she forgave
him why well re use modern therapy speak
to paper over his actions the woman is
still hurt but he feels her pain I do
regret regret proposing that day because
I wasn't fully ready and why did you I
think the pressure of this the pressure
being the bachelor knowing that there's
a time line and having to make that
decision on that day but you always have
a choice in you didn't need to make that
choice I know and I own up to that
that's on me that is totally on me I
have no excuse for that I apologize for
that and I forgive you I was sorry
ladies he's taken at least for three or
four more months so did Becca the
spurned ex-fiance learn her lesson that
seeking love on a reality show often
doesn't pan out the way one expects well
she agreed to be the Bachelorette in the
next series yes a show humiliates you
and your solution returned to the very
show that humiliates you it's like me on
the five Vande paraded all the new male
flesh for her to peruse and how quickly
re the creep was tossed on the heap as
one
showed up with a majestic speed so who
needs an ass when you can have a horse
I wish Becca the best of luck and look
forward to seeing Ari on the cover of Us
Weekly inevitably caught making out with
a groupie at a promotional event for
cheap vodka